[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, good afternoon,
everyone and thank you
for coming to the session on
the last series of sessions
on the first day of
Google Cloud Next.
My name is Anthony Heilig and
I'm a technical program manager
IN Google Cloud.
And Kubeflow is one of
the partner programs
that I am responsible for.
And I'll be presenting
this afternoon's session
along with Vinod and
Nicholas from H2O.ai.
So you can think of Kubeflow
as TensorFlow packaged up
into Kubernetes containers to
make it easier for everyone
to deploy, develop, and manage
their portable distributed
machine learning on Kubernetes.
Because what we were
seeing is people
were doing this
in different ways,
and everybody had
their own solution,
their own architecture.
And everybody had rolled their
own custom bespoke thing.
And what we started the
Kubeflow project we said,
you know what, this
looks a lot like what
we were seeing with
containers before Kubernetes
was developed back in 2014.
So everybody had their own way
of developing their container
solution and we wanted to
standardize those APIs.
And Kubernetes has
helped us to do that.
And it allows the
developers to really focus
on the higher value things
and not necessarily worry
about the infrastructure
and how everything else
is plumbed together.
And so if we already
had that Kubernetes,
why wasn't it easy to just
throw TensorFlow into the mix
and everything work?
Well, it turns out that there's
a lot you have to do in order
to really make this
work, especially
the portable distributed
portion of it.
So you would have to become
an expert in containers,
and packaging,
Kubernetes service
endpoints, persistent
volumes, et cetera, et cetera.
And we just wanted to eliminate
the developers' responsibility
with becoming an
expert in all of these
and really get them back to
developing their application.
And also, once they
develop it once,
being comfortable
that they could run it
in several different places,
because the goal of Kubeflow
was, Kubeflow is to run
anywhere Kubernetes runs.
So if we could fix this, we
could really make life easier
for you.
And so that's why
we built Kubeflow.
We wanted to turn having
separate experimentation,
training, and cloud clusters,
on the right-hand side
of this picture,
and this workflow
that you see on the
left side, which
is a traditional machine
learning workflow
where you start a
data ingest, and then
you end up with
logging, and then
the loop feeds back on itself.
And then you can
retrain, et cetera.
So what this becomes with
Kubeflow is your architecture
becomes a Kubernetes
installation.
This workflow is taken
care of with Kubeflow.
And then you can
do experimentation
on your laptop via mini queue.
You can do training in
your on-premises cloud
or some other small cluster
installation that you may have.
And then you can
push to the cloud.
And again, Kubeflow makes
all of this seamless
because it's hiding all of the
nuances of getting everything
from an infrastructure
point of view
underneath the covers
that is Kubernetes.
And Kubeflow
maintains the machine
learning aspect, the
distributed nature,
making sure you can use
the different resources,
whether it be CPUs, GPUs,
or TPUs on Google Cloud.
And so what we wanted to
do was to make it easier
to bring these subject matter
experts to machine learning,
because this is that
next level of unlocking
that we're trying to do.
Because once we get these
subject matter experts
with the deep domain
expertise that they
can talk more the language
about the problems
they're trying to solve,
as opposed to trying
to have to deal with all of the
infrastructure and making sure
everything is plumbed
together and works correctly.
This is the vision that we have.
And so with this
introduction to Kubeflow,
I'd like to turn it over
to Vinod and Nicholas
from H2O.ai to give you an
example of some of the things
that you can do with Kubeflow.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for the
great introduction.
Going to skip into the next one.
So I'm Vinod Iyengar.
I've been with H2O
for about three years.
I run a lot of the product
alliances and marketing at H2O.
So talk a little about
who we are as a company.
Quick show of hands.
How many people have heard
about H2O, the company,
or used one of our
open source products?
That's quite a few.
Oh, great.
Perfect.
So this one is, I
guess, [INAUDIBLE]..
But we've been in business
for about six years.
We are a venture backed company.
We are about 100 employees now.
That number is a little dated.
Some of the world's
leading AI experts working.
Most folks know us for the
H2O open source machine
learning platform that's used
by over 40,000 organizations
globally.
Most recently, we
launched a new product
called Driverless AI, which
is our automated solution.
And we'll talk about that in
a little bit of detail later.
We are headquartered in Mountain
View, right across from Google,
on the other side.
And we have offices in
London, Prague, and India.
Recently, Gartner
named us as a leader
in the machine learning and
data science magic quadrant.
They called us a technology
leader with the most
completeness of vision.
What they mean by that is
that our technology bets,
our mindshare, partner network,
ecosystem, essentially made
us the quasi industry
standard for machine learning
and AI when it comes
to enterprises.
So most of the vendors
on this quadrant,
for example, they actually
use our open source platforms
under the hood.
So that gives us a real
credibility in the enterprise.
One other thing
that I'm extremely
proud about is our customers
gave us the highest
overall score amongst all
vendors for satisfaction,
relationship, account
management, and support.
And that's something that
we take extreme pride about.
We make sure that our
customers get the best
service and experience.
So just to talk about the
issue of products suite,
so as I mentioned,
most folks know us
for the open source products
that are on the left.
You see H2O open source, H2O
Core as we call it internally.
That's the in-memory distributed
machine learning algorithms.
That comes in our
pipeline or you
can use it with H2O Flow,
which is our own interactive
[INAUDIBLE] interface.
There's Sparkling Water, which
is essentially H2O Core that
runs on top of Apache Spark.
That's extremely popular too.
Nearly a third of all our open
source usage comes from that.
And last year we
made the decision
to start deporting some of
these algorithms over to GPUs.
So I'm talking about statistical
machine learning algorithms,
not just deep planning, which
is already being [INAUDIBLE]
on GPUs.
You port it over things
like GLMs, Random Forest,
gradient boosted machines,
clustering algorithms,
dimension algorithms.
So the core traditional machine
learning algorithms, those
are now also ported
over to GPUs.
And on the right, you see our--
well, right for you,
our commercial offering.
First enterprise offering
called Driverless AI,
which takes all the
benefits of open source,
but packages it all together
to give you full automation end
to end.
You can go from data ingest
all the way to production.
All the intermediate steps,
like feature engineering,
model building, training,
[INAUDIBLE] tuning,
are all taken care of.
So in a way, I mean,
our goal is very similar
to-- as we said, our goal
is to democratize machine
learning and AI,
make it really easy,
give the tools and the products
for enterprises, developers,
and data scientists to do
the jobs really easily so
that they can focus on
solving business problems.
So let me talk about our
two core products over here,
and then we'll see
a demo later done
by Nick, who's going to actually
show how all of our products
integrate really well with
Kubeflow, and in general
with Google Cloud.
So if you are committed
to using Google Cloud,
and if you saw
the keynote today,
there's a lot of
amazing announcements.
You can take advantage of
all those amazing new things
with H2O's offerings.
So very quick overview on H2O.
We call it H2O Core internally.
So what is it?
It's essentially
a math platform.
So it's an open source
in-memory engine.
What we've done is we've
taken the most common machine
learning algorithms
like, as I mentioned,
the GLMs of the world, Random
Forest, gradient boosted trees,
and we rewrote them
from scratch to be fully
parallelized and distributed.
So you can essentially spin
up multiple machines as long
as your--
if your data is large, you
just spin up more machines
and we can handle all the data.
And that really works well in
the Kubernetes and Kubeflow
paradigm too, because
when you are training
on small data on your
laptop, for example,
then if you want
to burst to cloud
for a much larger dataset,
it's extremely easy to do that.
It is written in Java, but we
do offer a really robust REST
API that allows you
to run it from R,
Python, or H2O Flow,
which our own web UI.
And of course, it is built
for handling big data.
So people have run
terabytes of data,
and even gone into like
hundreds of terabytes of data
without an issue.
You can use all of your data.
You don't really need to sample.
That's the real value
proposition of H2O.
So what kind of
algorithms do we support?
So this is just a select list
of some other algorithms.
As you can see, most of the
classic statistical learning
algorithms, tree-based methods,
neural networks, deep learning,
dimension [INAUDIBLE]
algorithms.
And we also support a lot of
enterprise learning techniques,
like class training,
time series,
stuff like ISAX,
virtual embedding
like [INAUDIBLE] and TFIDF.
But in addition, we do a lot of
hyperparameter tuning options
that are given, and in
an easy to use format.
One of the things
we did is we created
very thoughtful defaults for
each of those parameters,
so that even as a
new user, if you
don't know what those
parameters mean,
you don't have to figure out.
It can still run a good
model, good enough model,
and then come back and
start hitting them.
In addition, we also
added an automatic machine
learning implementation
so that it
can run through a whole
bunch of algorithms,
try a bunch of tuning parameters
for you, all automatically,
and give you a good result.
So when you think about the
typical machine learning
workflow, going back
to Anthony's slide,
on the left side if you will, so
you have your data integration
happening.
Bring data in from
different silos or tables,
do your joins, if you will.
And once you're done,
you have a machine
learning running data frame.
At each point, you do feature
engineering model building
and a model requirement.
So H2O3 essentially fits in the
model building and deployment
stage.
So you need to do your
own feature engineering.
You need to do your data
[INAUDIBLE] transformation,
but once the data is in
a good enough format,
you can use the H2O algorithms
to run on the whole dataset
and build models.
So from an architecture
perspective,
this is how it looks.
What happens under
the hood is you have--
on the left, you've got
all the data sources.
Obviously, we support most
common enterprise data sources.
Pull in data from
wherever you have.
Once the data is in H2O, the
H2O data frame essentially,
it's a distributed
key value store
that distributes the whole
data across all the nodes you
have up and running.
And this is all abstracted
for the end user.
End user doesn't
need to know how
the distribution is happening.
And then you can
do expert analysis
and feature engineering.
You can run one of the
different algorithms
we support, go through
hyperparameter tuning,
do the evaluation scoring.
And all of these steps
that you do in H2O
are all fully distributed
for you under the hood.
So we take care of
the work, like doing
the non-blocking
hash tables, doing
the in-memory map reduces,
distributed fork joints.
All those things are
fully abstracted,
so you as an end user
don't have to worry.
So what do you write--
the code that runs on your
laptop, one minor change
will run on a cluster.
So it's as easy as that.
And then the cool part is after
you've done all the modeling,
you can export the artifacts
as either a plain old Java
object or a model
object and deploy it
into a whole bunch of
scoring environments.
This code is highly optimized
for low latency scoring.
So you're talking about
microsecond and millisecond
level latency.
And it is completely independent
of the training cluster.
So you can shut down
the training cluster,
take the scoring artifact and
put it to deployment anywhere.
So it's a really clean end
to end story for enterprises,
and even for any dataset.
So that was H2O
Core open source.
So let's look at
Driverless AI for a second.
So what is Driverless AI?
So we think of it as an expert
data scientist in a box.
So what we did is we
took all the learnings
we had from or five or
six years of open source
usage from the community
and from our customers,
and we took the learnings from
that and created the software.
So it's actually
built by the experts.
The expert data scientists
have built the software.
We've taken their best
practices, their heuristics,
their workflows, and codified
that in the software.
I'm sure most
people who are here
have heard about Kaggle, right?
If not, Kaggle is this
dataset is supported
by people for [INAUDIBLE].
It's actually owned
by Google as well.
But we essentially hired five
of the top 100 grandmasters
from Kaggle, and we
took their workflows
and basically codified it.
So you're essentially getting
grandmaster level machine
learning with this product.
And how do we do that?
So again, let's go back
to this enterprise machine
learning workflow.
So you have data coming
in from different sources.
You still need to do that.
You need to do the ETL part.
You need to do the data quality
and transformation as well.
We do some of it,
but not a whole lot.
But once the data is in a
single data source, if you will,
a single file or a data
frame, at that point on,
you can let Driverless
take care of everything.
So we do all the feature
engineering for you.
We'll do the
[INAUDIBLE] encoding.
We'll do the target encoding.
We'll do dimensional
data reduction for you.
We'll find the right
interaction elements.
And all of those things
automatically for you,
depending on the type
of the dataset, type
of problem [INAUDIBLE].
So all you need to do
as a user is specify
what you're trying
to predict and we'll
take care of that point.
And then in parallel, we
do model building as well.
So it's a very intertwined
process-- feature engineering
and model building back
and forth iteratively.
And goes through this entire
process to give you a pipeline.
This pipeline will now have all
the feature engineering steps
that it thought were useful
and the final model or ensemble
that it picked to be
the most effective.
And this pipeline is
generated as code for you.
So again, going back to
the original paradigm,
you want deployment
ready code that
is independent of
the training cluster.
So you can take
the code and deploy
into production on the
edge if you want to.
And finally, we do
another cool thing,
is we actually try to
interpret the model for you.
So what we're trying to
solve is three things.
There's a lot of things
happening in this slide,
but essentially, it's
talent, time, and trust.
We found that those are the
three big reasons, hurdles,
obstacles to
enterprise AI adoption.
So talent is-- there is a
deep lack of expert AI talent.
That's no news to anyone.
The data scientists are
a hot commodity to find.
And they are
extremely [INAUDIBLE]
hire and keep as well.
So what do all the enterprises
around the world do?
So that's a big challenge.
The second problem is of time.
It takes a lot of time to build
models, train them effectively.
And even with all
the advances that
have happened in
the hardware side,
you don't have the software
to take advantage of it.
And finally, even once
you build a good model,
these models often don't go to
production because the business
users don't trust them.
Enterprises, the regulators
are afraid of black box models.
There is inherent lack
of trust in the air.
So how do we solve
all these problems?
Basically, we solve that by
using Driverless AI to deliver
additional data scientists that
can solve the talent problem.
It can make your existing
work force more effective.
We solve the time problem by
automating the entire workflow,
and also using the latest GPUs
and hardware to accelerate
the machine learning workflow.
So you can give your
results in a matter of hours
instead of what would
take weeks or months.
And finally, every
model we build,
we are able to generate
explanations for you that
are fully interpretable.
So the question comes
up, how accurate are we?
I mean, automation is cool.
[INAUDIBLE] is the buzzword
now, but is it really good?
So what we did is we actually
took Driverless AI to task
and we participated
in Kaggle as a bot.
So in some of the
competitions [INAUDIBLE]
so this one in particular
is pretty cool.
The BNP Paribas,
this was a year old.
Out of the box,
Driverless AI came
number 10 on the leaderboard
out of about 3,000 participants.
So just for context,
so all the people
who ranked higher than
Driverless AI, on average,
had about anywhere from
10 to 25 submissions.
A couple of people had like
over hundreds of submissions.
And then these people
spent weeks, if not months,
to get a higher score.
And in the matter
of a few hours,
Driverless AI came
ranked number 10.
So it can perform at the
level of an expert Kaggle
grandmaster.
That's what we're
talking about here.
And this is not just
one competition.
We participated in a bunch
of other competitions.
And it typically
comes in the top five,
and sometimes top one percentile
without any human intervention.
And just to give you a
sneak preview of what's
happening under
the hood, so you're
talking about these features.
These are the features
that get created.
Some of these
automatically generated
features, things like text
handling, frequency encoding,
cross validated target encoding,
and truncated SVD, for example.
These are all complex features
that, A, you don't know--
if you know how
to use them, it's
painful to actually
code them up in Python
and then try to run them on
all the different combinations
if possible.
So it's a lot of time
and effort that's
required if you
know the expertise.
And we do that all
for you [INAUDIBLE]..
So one final thing
about deployment.
After the model is built,
as I mentioned earlier,
you do get a Java artifact.
So you can get the
POJO or MOJO for H2.
And for Driverless also,
you can get the MOJO file.
That's essentially
a zip file that
contains the binary
representation of the model.
And it also contains
all the feature
engineering information.
And it's completely
self-independent.
It's self-sufficient, doesn't
have any dependencies,
so you can put it
into the edge, you
can run it wherever you have
a Java runtime environment.
And obviously, it's easy to add
other language bindings too,
but that's a really
cool deployment story.
So you can have one of these
models running on your phone,
for example.
And it'll still give
you low latency scoring.
It can give you some
millisecond response times.
So you don't have to call
a REST API or an endpoint
if you don't have to.
We can embed these
applications in your software.
Cool.
With that, I am going to invite
Nicholas over to talk about,
how does H2O fit into
Google Cloud's Platform?
NICHOLAS PNG: Hello, everyone.
So we're just going to
talk of a couple of things.
First off is just a
couple of pipelines
that we've run on GCP slash
played with in GCP as a preempt
to the final one, which
is our demo on Kubeflow.
Obviously, it
being in the title,
it should come last and be
the most important thing.
So firstly, we have just
a high level deployment
of the pipeline that we might
suggest if you are already
utilizing Spark.
So a lot of
companies already use
Spark as part of their
data engineering platform.
What this does provide
to you is the ability
to ingest data directly
through Google Dataproc, which
is Google's offering
of Apache Spark.
And it makes things very
easy because you don't have
to set up the infrastructure.
Google sets up and pulls up
the infrastructure for you.
And then what we
can do is actually
play on top of that using our
offering of Sparkling Water
and H2O.
And you can do
your data munging,
you can do your
data engineering.
And then once you're
done with that,
you can output the final
file into Driverless AI.
From here, Driverless AI can
do all the wonderful things
that Vinod did mention.
We will allow for automatic
feature engineering,
automatic hyperparameter
tuning and model building.
And then you can serve
the final model out
as a MOJO or a Python scoring
package in, again, GCE.
Now, both Driverless AI and
the MOJO scoring pipelines
can all be served
on VMs in the GCP,
so on Google Compute Engine.
And the nice thing is
that you can actually
have a smaller platform
that doesn't necessarily
need GPUs to serve MOJOs,
because they don't actually
need the GPUs.
So then another one, just
another quick pipeline
that we did have is just
going straight from BigQuery.
And this does highlight a little
bit of the integration work
that we've done as far as data
ingest with Driverless AI.
Essentially, the data
is still stored in--
well, in this case, it would
be stored directly in BigQuery.
The other ones, obviously,
are kind of moot in this case.
But you can do the data
munging directly in BigQuery,
meaning formulate
a select statement
or formulate a SQL query
that gets you the data
that you want, at which
point you can actually
just copy-paste that same
SQL statement directly
into the Driverless AI UI
through the data ingest.
At which point you would be
able to just simply ingest
that data and Driverless
will grab that data
and then be able to run with it.
Same backend of the pipeline.
And finally, we're going to
just talk a quick highlight
before we get to a demo here
of just H2O plus Kubeflow.
So the idea being is that the
one nice thing about Kubernetes
and Kubeflow in general is
that, one, Kubernetes allows you
to distribute your workload.
So you don't necessarily need
to give over a whole machine
to a program that's
running, or only
really needs one CPU and
maybe a couple gigs of RAM
to support it.
Now obviously, a
lot of this stuff,
H2O's Core product
in Driverless AI
would require significantly
higher resources.
But the nice thing is, if
you had a cluster on GKE,
you're able to distribute
the workload for H2O Core.
And then maybe also
on top of this--
and this is something
I'll show in the example--
also deploy another pod
that contains Driverless.
And it's all running on
the same infrastructure.
It's all very easy to do,
because all you need to do
is just give it two Docker
containers, one for H2O and one
for Driverless AI,
which we do provide.
Cool.
So at this point, let
me just sign in here.
OK, so we're going to
just go over a quick demo.
Now, what I have here
is, on the left-hand side
is going to be the GitHub repo.
So this is actually public.
It's H2O AI slash H2O Kubeflow.
So if you take a look up here.
This is actually going to be
merged into the actual Kubeflow
repo eventually.
I think at the moment we
have an open issue for it.
And then I just want to show
you my infrastructure right now.
We have a quick,
small demo cluster.
So it's not tiny, but
it's not enormous either.
But basically, it comes down
to we have about 32 CPUs
plus some x number of RAM.
And it's a GKE cluster, so
it's running on Google GCP.
Also another quick look,
but basically, the two VMs,
that's all that is there.
So on the right-hand
side, we have a terminal.
Now, Kubeflow
basically allows you
to use something called
Ksonnet as a package that
allows for templating.
And this is one of the really
great things of Kubeflow
in my opinion, as an
addition to Kubernetes,
is Kubernetes itself, when
you want to make a deployment,
you have to create a YAML
file or a manifest file
and say explicitly that this
is the runtime environment
that my container needs to have.
And now if I go part
two, if, for example,
my original container
was a testing container
and only needed four CPUs and a
bit of RAM to go along with it,
then the next one needed
to be much more powerful,
then you would have to
actually change the YAML file.
You'd have to actually
change the manifest,
request more resources.
And that can be a
pain in the butt,
especially if you are not
in an environment where
you can easily
change these things,
or if you're trying to do
it automatically, right?
The cool thing with Kubeflow
is that if you do ks init--
and so this is
actually the directory
that has already been init-ed.
But I'll actually go back just
to show you the idea behind it.
So if I do ks init and then
demo demo, what that will do
is create--
yeah, sorry, ks init demo demo--
what that's doing
is it's actually
creating a folder,
organizing kubectl to point
to that specific folder.
And basically, setting up
the runtime environment
under which you can actually
deploy Kubeflow, as well
as deploy anything
else within that area.
So now we'll actually go
back to Kubeflow demo here.
Sorry.
And so what you'll
see here is basically
what Ksonnet has created.
So you'll see some environments.
You'll see some components.
And you'll see an app.yaml.
So if we look into components
here, what that's showing
you is some of the components
that I've already added.
Ksonnet allows you
to add a registry.
Now, a registry
actually adds a list
of packages that
you can install,
after which you install
specific packages.
So if I do ks pkg list, you'll
actually see that I've in--
it'll actually show
you-- the asterisk
shows that it's installed here.
So I've installed
our H2O package.
I've also installed
Driverless AI.
I've installed the
Kubeflow core packages.
And these are all running,
so if I do kubectl get pods,
I actually have a couple of them
running already pre-baked so
that I can actually show you
what's going on the front end
as well as on the backend.
So from the point
where we're at here,
you've installed the packages
using ks pkg install.
And then you'd actually
just write out--
so it'd be h2o-kubeflow
in this instance.
And then I can do /h2o3-scaling.
So I haven't installed
this package.
It's basically a
work in progress,
but gives you the example of how
you would install said package.
From here, if we
kubectl get pods--
get sbc-- so this is actually
showing you the endpoints.
I'm using a load balancer to
expose the port numbers so
that I can actually use
their APIs in the web browser
or in a Jupyter notebook
or something of the sort.
But then the last step after
you've installed the package
would be ks prototype use
io.ksonnet.pkg.h2o3-static.
And this is basically
like the first line.
And you can actually
read through a lot
of these deployment
steps here in the repo.
So I'm not going to go any
further than giving you
the first step, but
what this is doing
is that it's actually
creating those components
that I showed you initially.
So again, if you ls
into the components,
you can see that after using
prototype use, what you get
is this component installed
in the Ksonnet app.
And if you'll notice
here, you would
have had to take a
couple parameters
and pass a couple of parameters.
So actually, that's going
to be this file right here.
So if you take a look
at the parameters,
you can actually see that
it sets some parameters
for each of the components
that have been deployed.
So now we're actually going
to just dive a little bit
deeper into after
you've deployed.
So sorry, just one last
quick thing. ks apply
is going to be how
you actually deploy.
So ks apply the
specific environment
that you want, and then
also the component.
So in this case, h2o3-static
would be one of the components
that I had already created.
When you do that, what you're
ultimately going to get
is the package along
with the parameters is
going to be passed to Kubeflow.
And that's going to
deploy your packages
and pull up as many
replicas as were requested,
as well as pull up the
specific resources allocated
to each pod.
So now-- we're going to go
quickly first to the H2O
deployment.
And this is H2O Core.
So if you go to the external
API in the load balancer,
and it's just HTTP
and then 54321,
which is the exposed port, you
can see that this is H2O Flow.
So this is actually what Vinod
was talking about earlier.
This is our basically
simplified GUI.
So it's very similar to
Jupyter notebook in the sense
that it gives you a
step-through notebook.
And you can do some
more simplistic steps.
Rather than coding
this in Python,
you can actually
just go import files.
And I can set a
variable that says
variable is locA for location
A is equal to some string here.
And then import the
file, just like this.
And instead of using
Pythonic language,
it's very clearly just one step
next, do the next thing, right?
And I'm going to go
ahead and leave that now.
So now, if we go to
a Jupyter notebook.
Sorry about that.
Let's open up the demo.
So I have-- just basically,
this is just a quick notebook
showing you what would happen.
You would import.
And this would be from
your local computer.
You can import the H2O packages,
connect to the specific URL
plus endpoint.
And it will actually
show you the resources.
So we have a cluster
of three nodes.
That's because that's the
deployment package that I made.
Go ahead and import some data.
Go ahead and set up some data.
And this is running
through a demo
that's on our documentation.
So if you do look
at docs.h2o.ai,
you can actually
see the same demo,
or something fairly similar.
Ultimately, what this
is coming down to is
we're running H2O's
AutoML package.
The AutoML meaning that it's
going to do an intense grid
search across several different
algorithms that we have
and try and find the best one.
And you can track progress here.
Basically, all I've done
is set a single parameter
here saying that don't
run more than 120 seconds.
But basically,
take any algorithms
that you want, try
as much as you can,
and give me the best
possible result.
So while it's
running, I'm actually
going to show you the other
product that's running,
which is Driverless AI.
So Driverless AI, it's
exposed at this IP right here,
and just the port number 12345.
So if I go 12345, you'll see
Driverless AI is running.
And I've actually loaded a
couple of datasets already.
In case you're not
familiar with this,
the first step would be going
through and adding a dataset.
We do have direct integration
to Google BigQuery, as well as
Google Cloud Storage.
So if I were wanting to
go to Google BigQuery,
again, you can go and type
in the dataset ID right here.
You can type in the
GCS bucket right here.
And then you can do
some sort of select.
So SELECT * FROM DATASET.
Just in the interest
of time, I'm
actually just going
to close that window
and show you from
what we have already.
So what I have here is
one time series datasets.
So this is a Walmart dataset
that was from Kaggle.
Basically, it's predicting the
weekly sales of a Walmart store
in series of time.
So the first thing
that Driverless AI does
is it gives you a
couple of options
straight from the Dataset tab.
First, you can describe it.
So basically, what this
is doing is giving you
some statistical inference.
It's telling you what
type of values they are,
how many values there
are, and if there
are any missing, and
mean, min, max, just
some very basic statistics.
A lot of you would see
something fairly similar
if you went to pandas
and did pandas.describe.
The next thing that we do
have is visualizations.
So this is a package
that we call AutoVis.
AutoVis basically gives
you the opportunity
to create visualization
plots automatically.
So Driverless does this
automatically for you.
And what it's going to
show is a lot of the plots
that, as a data scientist,
you probably want to know.
Outlier plots are
very important.
Seeing if that maybe,
for some reason,
the whole distribution is
here, but for some reason
there's some data
points that are kind
of lying way out on the side.
And so this would be on
a specific column here.
And if you scroll through, you
can see each different column.
Same goes for-- you
can get radar plots.
You can get histograms
or skewed histograms.
Correlation graphs
are also really cool.
And you can see the correlation
between store or is holiday,
everything seems to be
correlated is holiday.
And that makes a lot of sense
considering this is retail.
And then after this, you
can create an experiment.
So the first steps, we're all
like, oh, is the data good?
Did I import the right dataset?
Do I feel comfortable with
running experiment on this?
Once I go there, now
I can go to predict.
I'm ready to do a prediction.
And so at this point,
you can run a prediction.
And that means adding a test
dataset if you so choose.
If you do not add a
test dataset, it's fine.
Driverless AI will
notice and automatically
use cross-validation
folds to test and train.
So it will do testing
and validation
on the out-of-fold data
so that you don't ever
have to worry about, well,
about cheating, essentially.
So time column-- this is
a time series dataset.
It's one of those things where
we do need to address time.
And we don't want
to look at September
to predict August sales, right?
So you can always set
Auto for time column.
Otherwise, if you know
the specific time column,
you can actually go
in and say, OK, well
that's actually just the date.
And then from here,
you can actually
select how many
weeks do you want
to predict forward,
how many weeks after do
you want to predict.
And always, Auto is optional.
Otherwise, you can go in and
select it more specifically.
Then finally, as we
said, a target column.
So this, in this case,
would be weekly sales.
And from here, you
get the final step,
which is you select your score.
So RMSE, RMSLE,
RMSPE, MAE, these
are all scores for regression.
And the reason is because
you're predicting a revenue.
So this would be a
regression problem.
And you have three knobs--
Accuracy, Time, and
Interpretability.
Interpretability is just
how interpretable do
you want on a scale of 1 to 10.
0 interpretability,
or 1, would mean
that you don't mind having a
very complex model, versus 10
is saying make it as
simple as possible.
Make it so that the feature
transformations are all very
clear and easy to understand.
Time-- less time means take a
shorter amount of time to run,
or more time, meaning take
longer to run, I don't mind.
Run as long as you need.
Accuracy-- how high do
I prioritize accuracy?
So is accuracy more important?
Can I have a more complex
model, things like that.
At which point, then you
can click Launch Experiment.
So once you launch, it will
give you this kind of UI.
From here, you can
watch as we progress
through the [INAUDIBLE]
and see more iterations.
As variables change, you'll
see variable importance here.
And you can check on CPU usage,
an actual versus predicted
graph, as well as
some just logging
and trace values up front.
I actually have already
completed data, or passed,
so I'm actually just
going to show you
that right here so that we
can talk about it a bit.
But what it comes down to
is you can see now the graph
has filled itself in.
You can actually
take a look here.
This is kind of cool,
because this is actually
showing that the only data
point that was actually
kept that is from
the original dataset
is Department, of the top five.
So you can see that some of
them are target lag values.
One of them is a
clustered value.
So this is using a clustering
algorithm of our making,
so we clustered the values
between Department and Markdown
number 4.
And from that, we
actually created
a new value that
is going to become
the value in that column.
And then finally, there's also
another lag value at the top
here.
So the other thing you
can take a look at here
is the iteration.
So over time, it started
out with a couple models.
And you can see
there's some outlier
models which were really,
really not high performant.
Obviously, RMSE meaning the
lower RMSE the better, right?
So we started out at
around 2,600 RMSE.
And then finally, the final
model they were predicting
is a little bit less than that.
So over time,
basically-- and this
is if we had given it more time,
if we had made it a little bit
less interpretable, if we had
higher prioritized accuracy,
it'll progress a
little bit more.
But for these
settings, this is what
you would expect is that over
time, we'd progress and find
a certain point where it
would stop, because it said,
OK, this was good enough.
This is kind of what
you were expecting.
And I'm just going to
quickly talk about this.
We didn't run a pre-baked
MLI, but this is machine
learning interpretability.
Essentially, what it comes
with is three packages--
or three surrogate models--
a random forest, a singular
decision tree, and K-LIME.
So K-LIME is essentially LIME,
but K number of LIME models.
What that does is
it creates a series
of linear models,
essentially, that approximate
what the actual model is doing.
So it's basically trying
to give you linear betas.
The same idea as like
a linear regression,
you have a beta
on each point that
will explain how a
change in that data point
would affect the prediction.
So that's K-LIME.
The next one is
random forest, which
will give you local
plots, which are basically
feature importance, but
positive and negative.
There's also a
feature importance
which is just positive.
And then finally,
there's a decision tree
which allows you to trace the
path of a singular decision
tree.
Very straightforward.
If I saw it at this specific
column, why I made a decision.
[MUSIC PLAYING]